hey everybody i'm nate from hugging face
and today we have a conversation between
myself and sandra steenberg
zander is an independent ai researcher
digital artist public speaker online
educator and founder of the wizard.ai
digital media platform
you might know him from his fantastic
youtube channel archive insights where
he covers and breaks down various papers
and topics in the machine learning
landscape
in this chat we'll go over how he got
into machine learning what his
educational journey was like and where
he sees the field of generative machine
learning going
this talk is actually part of the hogan
sprint where community members are
training and sharing generative models
so if you're interested and you're
watching this before april 14th 2022 you
can find more information about joining
in the description thanks for watching
and i hope to see you there without
further ado here's xander yeah yeah
anyways uh thank you for joining me um
i think people are really excited to to
hear from you uh uh especially around uh
generative models you know we have this
this hugging sprint going on right now
um which which is all about uh uh
training generative models and and uh a
lot of really cool interesting things
and i know that you you uh you you were
pretty interested in these things so um
but first off i think i think uh one
thing i always like to ask people that
are in that are in the field of machine
learning is how did you end up in the
field of machine learning
yeah so i mean i i studied uh
engineering here in the university of
ghent in in belgium and like my
engineering degree was actually in like
electronics
um but you know during my master's i
kind of realized hey electronics is not
really my thing it's also like kind of
slow it takes a long time to develop a
chip and so through my thesis i kind of
went into this like area of like brain
computer interfaces where people are
using these ej headsets you get like
these brain waves and you're using
machine learning basically to figure out
what what the brain is doing and you
know
this was like the first time that i was
doing ml and i was like really impressed
by by the fact that these machine
learning models they can make sense of
data that as a human when you look at it
it's just like total noise like
any any patterns in there and you know
we were able to build like really
impressive um tools with that and and
this like made me really
want to pursue that career and then i
don't think i've ever looked back since
you know i've been i've been doing
machine learning ever since yeah
so uh can you talk a little bit more
about that that journey and how you
learned more about machine learning
because uh when i when i looked online
so sorry go ahead go no you go ahead
so like
i i think when i graduated um you know
machine learning was not really as big
or as popular as it is now like you know
i graduated in 2014 so this was like two
years after you know alexnet famously
had this like neural network
breakthrough on imagenet and so it was
still like the very early days of deep
learning like i remember during my
thesis you know we were mostly using
like these traditional old cool machine
learning methods like you know lda and
svms and all these like kernel methods
and like neural networks was like you
know there was like the the new kid on
the block but like not too many people
were actually doing
neural networks
and so i started my first job as like a
data scientist and my thesis was done in
matlab and they told me hey actually you
know in the professional domain we
usually use python so you should go
ahead and and learn some python but the
first thing i did you know the first two
weeks of my job i was basically learning
how to do python
and then you know i started doing a
bunch of projects um
and and i'm really grateful for for
being like a consultant for two years
because it exposes you to very different
areas but i soon realized that i was
actually really interested in like the
technical side of things and so actually
you know all of my commutes i would
spend uh like all my time on the train
basically reading machine learning
papers
so i was basically trying to catch up
all this missing information that i
didn't get from my education so i i
think i i learned most of it uh by
myself really and and i think the main
driver for me has always been like
curiosity like i never felt forced to
learn anything because someone told me
that i that i should do this or that i
always had this like intrinsic
motivation like oh these methods they
look really interesting and i want to
learn what's going on and so a lot of it
is like you know self-driven right
that's that's awesome uh you know i
actually had a similar experience myself
too uh uh
and when i was taking courses i was a
business major uh i uh uh during class i
would just be studying studying python
uh yeah you know i'll be sitting there
in the back of my my computer studying
as well and uh yeah trying to fill in
those gaps
you know trying to find the things uh
that are gonna add value uh in the
future or something you know and i think
you get kind of obsessed right
yeah and i feel like you know if you
have this like personal intrinsic
motivation to learn about a field it's
just a much better driver than when some
professor tells you that you should
learn the syllabus or this i mean i i've
always felt like i wanted to be doing
this it's not like you know i i was
forced to do this or it's my job it's
always been like i really want to know
how this works
and and this kind of leads you to the
fact that you know
i'm i'm reading about this stuff like
all the time like whenever
when when i go to the bathroom i'll take
out my phone i'll i'll browse through
twitter there will be a bunch of paper
links and i'll just start reading them
because i really want to know what's
going on and so i feel like that's
really what people should be looking for
it's like which field or which subfield
really drives me in terms of curiosity
and motivation right and i think when
people you know it can take a it can
take your whole lifetime to sometimes
find a passion like that but once you do
find something like that it unlocks
education for you i think right like
because then education isn't like this
chore it's it's uh
it's a absolutely passion and i also
feel like you know like everyone who's
good at machine learning that i know is
continuously learning like like this
field is moving so quickly that you
can't really say that you're done
learning like this is a perpetual thing
right
right exactly it's a it's a lifelong
thing every single day uh learn a little
bit more right yeah
now uh what i also noticed online is
that um uh it seems that you went down a
path of of uh
teaching yourself using platforms like
coursera um uh
can you talk about uh maybe some tips
for folks who are venturing into their
own self-learning journeys
yeah this is a a question that i get
asked pretty often like hey which
courses did you do and and to be honest
like i only took one uh machine learning
course which i think was the one by jeff
dean
uh on on coursera on deep learning uh
but this was like a while ago like this
is probably like four years ago that i
took that course and so to be honest i
don't
actually know what the best resources
are right now for somebody who's
entering the field for the first time
because when i learned about it you know
this was like four or five years ago so
probably the resources have changed and
and since then
my main resource of basically keeping
track of everything is twitter i think
twitter is a really great uh space
because a lot of researchers are sort of
sharing their ideas and there's like
open discussions going on but i i think
reddit might just might be just as good
it's just that you know
you basically the thing i always tell
people is that you should try to figure
out a way to create your own filter
bubble like you have to
shape this bubble so that you get the
news that you want to get and you have
to and this this this takes a little bit
of time like on twitter
if you start making a new account like
the first month twitter won't be very
useful to you right but if you give it
some time you just start shaping this
bubble and you follow the right people
after a while it actually becomes a very
valuable resource so right you know i
stayed away from twitter for for years
and then i finally created one well i
finally started using mine uh
this past summer and now just now it's
really starting to become very valuable
so i think that's that's great advice
you know
um yeah i have the same thing like i had
a twitter account and i didn't use it
for like three years and then a friend
told me hey you should really use
twitter like it's really good and i
tried it again and you know like i had
some good pointers of people to follow
and then after a while it starts picking
up so it's kind of like a slow resource
but once you have that filter bubble
tuned it's actually super valuable yeah
what is it about machine learning where
everybody uh everybody in the machine
learning world is just on twitter and
just posting all this you know
really awesome content yeah it's
i don't really know why yeah i don't
know like i think the field is just
moving so quickly that all the other
forms of communication like email
threads or blog posts are always
slightly lagging the state of the art
because it's just going so quickly and
twitter feels like a really good medium
to to do like very quick flashy news
updates and then you get all this you
know these little posts and then the
things that you're really interested in
you click through and you actually read
into them deeper
yeah
yeah um
so uh what kind of things are you are
you working on right now
well um i'm i'm doing quite a few things
so like um my main job right now is that
i work for a biotech startup in boston
and so we're actually using um de novo
protein design using tools like alpha
fold for example right so there's this
big big breakthrough in in the biology
field with alpha fold and so it's like
the first time when like you know
proteins which are basically the the
molecular engines in your body that do
everything that make you alive we're
starting to understand like their
structures and how they actually perform
their function and it's the first time
in biology that people have really
started to to open up this box and and
we can start making things in a totally
new way kind of an interesting area to
work in but then at the same time like
in my spare time i'm i've been you know
for the past three years i've been
really passionate about like you know
digital art and generative media and so
i'm also really following the whole
space around like you know text to image
with like clip and vqgan and now the
fusion models and obviously dally
um so you know but it feels like you
know this space is just it's moving so
quickly it's insane like almost every
other week there's this new like
breakthrough state-of-the-art model that
that suddenly you know like you have
this reading list of papers that you
still want to check out and maybe
there's some code that you want to try
and run but it feels like before you can
get to that list there's always like
another approach that sort of like
overtakes all the other ones
so this this field is just insane like
the the speed of innovation here is
incredible right but then at the same
time too if you don't get to that
backlog of papers you don't understand
how the next ones came about too
which is like yes
yeah it is a struggle it is a struggle
yeah so like i mean uh
you know research around uh well
research in general but research around
generative models is changing
you know rapidly week by week and
sometimes even day by day so i think a
lot of folks in our field sort of get
fatigued uh trying to keep up with all
that the latest and greatest research um
so how do you try to manage this is
there is there a method to your madness
on managing this issue or do you have
any tips here
um
i mean i i honestly don't because i'm
kind of almost drowning myself also like
it's it's
um
yeah i mean
i feel like there's this like trade-off
between um
learning and like understanding new
techniques and sort of keeping up with
the progress in the fundamental research
domain
versus like actually doing stuff and
experimenting and and producing content
right there there's this like trade-off
and and i feel like it's it's a very
tricky balance because on the one hand
you want to keep on top of like the
newest tools and you want to understand
how they work so you can actually use
them and build something cool but on the
other hand it also feels like if you're
constantly hopping to the newest paper
and the newest repo then you never
really get to dive in and build
something that's interesting and
actually make something so i i feel like
this trade-off is is very tricky like
like i noticed this for example when i
was you know in like a couple of months
ago i basically started um working on my
own like vqgan plus clip pipeline and so
i took a lot of these notebooks that
were in the open source domain
like you know there's a lot of different
people that were you know posting
notebooks and so i took ideas from all
these notebooks and i started building
my own code base
uh and i i really spent like a couple of
months and i i was pretty happy about
that and you know i used it for a couple
of different projects like i did some
nfts i did some video clips for for
producers
um
and now i'm at this point where like
this code base is actually really good
but the techniques that i'm using in
there are kind of like already outdated
like they're six months old but they're
kind of outdated already so the question
is like what do you do with all that
work like now you have a really good
nice code base but maybe the the models
in there are not that that
state-of-the-art anymore and so this
very weird sense that like all the work
that you've put into it is maybe not
really useful anymore
and so
yeah yeah i mean it's it's kind of like
this trade-off between
like you said you know uh if you don't
get your hands on the keyboard and
really learn it you're not gonna have a
really intuitive understanding of how
the technology works but at the same
time then if you if you do dive in
you're not using the state of the art
but i think it's really important to
to uh to do that that deep dive and get
your hands on the keyboard and really
and really do the work because um
you know i think that's when you're
really learning because i mean anybody
can jump to the next repo and run the
example script but uh being able to put
your your own um twist on things and
really you know take a couple months uh
to to yeah dive deeper although if i
have to be really honest i also feel
like we're entering this kind of like
paradigm shift where it used to be the
case in the past like five or six years
that if you wanted to use machine
learning
um and create something valuable with
with ai you had to be like a technical
person like a programmer you had to know
how these things work you know how to
clone a github repo maybe tweak some of
the code and make your own framework but
it feels like more and more the people
that can leverage machine learning
will not have to be technically schooled
like it feels like you know like in this
whole space of like clipart for example
there's people that are really good what
are called prompt engineers they're
really good at figuring out which
sentences produce really interesting
visual content
and those people often
are the artists that are making the best
clip arts and they might not necessarily
understand like all the technical
details that are happening in in that
code base but nonetheless they're able
to leverage these tools via co-left
notebooks and
whatnot to create really interesting
digital content so i feel like gradually
we're moving to this space where ai is
becoming
so adopted by a large mainstream
audience that the tools
actually become easy to use for anyone
regardless of technical knowledge and
right that's a very interesting
transition i think
right and i think uh you know uh we've
been seeing this quite a bit at hugging
face with with spaces you know with
people creating uh you know demo apps
where anybody can use them you know you
could send them to your grandma and your
grandma could be a prompt engineer right
uh
and then all of a sudden you know
machine learning's in the hands of
everybody so i think you're right this
this paradigm shift uh uh in the field
is yeah i think it's for the best right
because then you're getting the most
diverse group of people to be able to
use your yeah your models and things
like that there is however like an
another thing which is kind of tricky
and i'm actually happy that you guys are
directly sort of like addressing this
but like one of the things that you
start seeing is that a lot of these
state-of-the-art machine learning models
are are built by like these really large
research organizations open the eye or
deepmind um and and it's it's becoming
harder and harder to run these models on
like consumer hardware like if you have
a you know like even if you buy the best
consumer graphics card that you can get
from nvidia which is the one that i have
like the rdx 3090 you can't even run
gpd3 or any of these super fancy image
generation models just can't
and i feel like this is a little bit
tricky it's it's a little bit of a
dangerous slope because
you know at some point you could get to
this uh state of the world where only
these large big tech companies are able
to wield these very powerful ai tools
and so i feel like a lot more effort
should be put in in you know like
distributing these systems where maybe
you have a pool of nodes of people that
have a single gpu and they all
contribute to this entire server to
basically run large state-of-the-art
models in like a distributed
decentralized way and i think that's a
very interesting area to keep uh
developing because otherwise you know
these large companies are going to have
monopolies on some of the most
important technology in the world so
that's kind of like a quickie
right it's i think it's really important
to you know sort of crowdsource the
the hardware so that you know we can
make this stuff more accessible to
everybody i think that's i think that's
really what the you know
like you said otherwise uh
uh corporations are gonna be the only
ones who can run these these these
models which is kind of disheartening
yeah
um
so uh i noticed you know we talked about
how you're interested in these
generative ai models
can you talk a little bit about where
you see this
field going this field of being able to
extend the capabilities of human
creativity yeah
so i i used the term on twitter before
like i really look at these generative
models as like
um you know like you could sort of look
at them as like they're creating digital
content but but the way that i really
see them is like
i i i like the term like imagination
amplifiers
they're like you still need a human to
to to give it some input like what is
the thing that you want the machine
learning model to create for you like
like a prompt for example
and so i feel like what's what's going
to happen in the future is that there's
going to be a lot of very creative
people that are going to leverage all
these generative models to create very
interesting digital content and so like
right now it's mostly text to image
right but this is going to change like
it's going to be video it's going to be
music and soon it's going to be like
totally immersive 3d environments that
you can just like put on a vr headset
and just walk around in and so like
these are really like the kinds of
building blocks people talk about when
they're talking about things like the
metaverse for example right we all know
that increasingly we're spending a
fraction of our lives in this digital
world consuming and producing digital
content and so i really feel like these
these generative models are just an
extension
of the digital tools we already have
it's just that they take away a lot of
the the technical skill that's usually
required in making digital content like
people using photoshop or like different
kinds of video editing software or maybe
things like unity or blender that create
3d worlds and i feel like all of those
tools are going to get consolidated by
these really powerful machine learning
models
that can just be driven by language like
you just have to
have the creativity of imagining a
certain type of digital content or a
world and then you describe that to a
machine learning system and it will
actually produce the pixels for you
and so i feel like you know this is i i
totally understand that a lot of people
feel kind of threatened by this paradigm
because i mean we're talking about a lot
of jobs here
right
to be honest i i think you can kind of
like compare this with
you know when when the entire
agricultural industry got replaced by
tractors right nobody works as a farmer
anymore because we have tractors doing
all the hard work
so like all these jobs they're going to
become like the technical part is going
to become easy and and automated
but i still feel like
the the really important part is like
what's the narrative that these digital
tools are are building and i feel like
humans are still going to be driving the
narratives we're still going to have
creative people
that have a sense of what kinds of
digital content they want to make and
what what story they want to bring
but i i do feel like this is really
going to change the way that we interact
with digital content exactly i think you
know
i don't think human creativity is ever
going to go away i don't think anybody's
ever going to see an ai model and say oh
well i don't need to create now you know
i think it's the human experience to
want to create um art in general right
so um you know whether that's music or
or or digital media et cetera and uh you
know i think you know just like
photoshop changed uh
the game you know some of these uh uh
these tools are gonna change to be
honest i also think that we might soon
see the emergence of like
autonomous ai systems that produce
really interesting content like you know
there's been a lot of experiments with
like autonomous digital artists like i'm
i'm working with some i don't know if
you know gene cogan he has this really
interesting project called abraham and
so i'm kind of working
on abraham a little bit and so there's
this idea that in the near future we
will have this autonomous ai systems
that produce very interesting digital
content like digital art or maybe even
stories that they write and so i feel
like right now what we're consuming is
purely content created by people and i
think that that you know that line is
going to blend slowly and and there
might be very interesting content coming
from ai systems and
i don't necessarily see that as a bad
thing i mean i mean because i think the
more content there is to choose from the
more interesting content you can find
then i feel that's just enriching to the
human experience and what sort of
content are you thinking
i mean i'm pretty sure that in the not
too distant future we'll have like short
stories being purely written by ai
models that are like
very interesting maybe something like a
movie is a little bit further down the
line because that's even more
complicated um but yeah i can definitely
see ai starting to create short
narratives and i feel like this whole
revolution we've seen in like pixels you
know like image generation uh we're soon
going to see something similar in the
audio domain where there's going to be
very interesting types of music like
if you think about the entire field of
electronic music that was purely enabled
by computers you know like visual
synthesizers and computers and we could
suddenly make a totally new type of
sound i'm very sure that machine
learning can can produce even weirder
sounds that are totally different from
anything we've heard so far and
you know i'm really interested to see
what's what's what's gonna happen in the
future yeah i mean i think we saw a lot
of that with with like open ai jukebox
uh a while ago um uh but other other
tools like that i think i find so
fascinating as somebody who likes to
dabble with with some music stuff uh
music production stuff i think it's
really interesting for like creators uh
uh to be able to if we can get these
tools in the hands of creators because i
mean they're kind of useless if they're
just stuck in a research lab um but if
we're for making these tools available
so people can use them in their digital
audio workstations uh yeah that would be
so cool
there's like in terms of audio there's
like this weird artifact that i've had a
few conversations with with other people
it's like
for some weird reason it seems to be the
case that like modeling audio is
actually more difficult than images
and one of the
like potential explanations is that our
brains are are kind of
like if you produce an image where some
of the pixels are off
um that's actually fine like we either
see it as like there's a little bit of
noise or it might even have like an
artistic effect like it it's actually
something that we like
but as soon as you have some
like mistakes in the waveform of audio
it just sounds bad
so it feels like our brains are much
less like
you know we're much more sensitive to
mistakes in audio waveforms so it feels
like
you know there's still like some some
gap between like audio that sounds
really clear and really good versus what
we can generate now but i think that's
gap that gap's gonna it's gonna fade
really really quickly um right yeah i
mean i think i yeah like you said i
think we're a lot more sensitive to it i
think you know we want things to sound
punchy we want things to sound clear
with audio and and that's significantly
harder to you know that's like trying to
get a hd image generated it's it's it's
very uh yeah it's difficult
now speaking of speaking of uh uh
of of audio uh one like really
incredible thing that you've built is
this uh wizard dot ai i hope i'm
pronouncing that right wizard.
uh which is basically a platform which
lets you upload some audio and your site
will produce you know an ai generated
music video uh for it
um so can you talk about uh maybe
a little bit of the research that went
into creating this and maybe what sort
of the model is behind the scenes
yeah so this is actually like you know
the results of like one of my first few
experiments with like digital art and
generative models it's like um actually
the entire wizard platform is based on
style guide it's like this generated
model from nvidia uh because i i very
clearly remember that when stylegan was
released it was like the first time that
neural networks were able to generate
like high-definition images and i was
like wow this is this is like a total
gage
um but you know like the paper was
mainly focusing on these data sets like
faces for example you know we all know
this website this person does not
exist.com and so i saw a lot of media
attention for stylegan that was kind of
focusing on the negative aspect hey you
can you can generate fake faces and this
can be used for all kinds of nefarious
purposes
but i immediately thought like you could
create amazing artistic uh content with
this as well so the first thing i
started doing is i started training
stylegan on like
data sets of images that were purely um
aesthetic like images that looked
amazing in terms of colors and
composition and so i started training a
few of my own style game models um
i got some interesting like images and
interpolations but then i was like you
know like all these interpolations
they're kind of like just random smooth
videos and there's not really a lot of
narrative in there and so i thought you
know how could we make this a little bit
more interesting
and then i just thought about hey why
don't we like take audio music and i
built a little python script to do like
feature extraction so i do like uh
harmonic percussive decomposition and
you basically get like these nice
features that um contain like the rhythm
of the song and a little bit of the
melody
and then i started using those features
to basically drive the interpolation
through the latent space so maybe when
there's a beat you suddenly push the
latence forward or when something's
happening in the melody you change the
latence and so i started playing around
with this and i posted some videos on
twitter one of them went really viral
and so i was like hey people actually
like this kind of content and maybe
there might be other people that would
like to make their own content using
these tools
um and so i decided to basically turn
all of my python code into like a a
website like the media platform where
people can now just like they can select
a visual theme which is basically a
pre-trained style gun model that was
trained on a specific data set then you
can upload your own audio track it will
run like the whole audio analysis
pipeline
and then you can even you get like a
timeline so you can place certain images
on the timeline so you have some control
over the visual narrative and then you
can render the final video and you get
like this audio reactive texture
and i think one of the most interesting
things is when you don't take the output
of wizard as like the final result but
you then use this audio reactive texture
in you know secondary and even tertiary
uh software tools yeah right right
making it is like an extension to your
creative ability you know like we're
discussing yeah uh and hopefully i'll
i'll be able to include a clip
here or here
somewhere
i think it's it's super interesting so
so what are your what are your plans for
the the future with this this platform
do you have any plans here or is this
kind of like a one-off project
uh so i mean to be honest like the the
whole space of generative digital media
is moving so quickly that it's it's kind
of hard for me to figure out like you
know what do i actually want to work on
next like you know i told you i'm also
working on like protein design i'm doing
a bunch of digital art and so i don't
actually have like a very solid plan
other than then i'm really sure that i
want to keep doing stuff within this
space it's it's just a matter of like
you know which which tool do i want to
build on like i'm working on this
abraham project theme i have wizard
there's also all this new stuff with
like the fusion models and alley now so
it's like
this is the total jungle of
possibilities and it feels a little bit
hard to to pick one thing and and work
on it consistently right it's it's it's
overwhelming it's overwhelming um
for sure i know that we're we're close
to being on time so uh i think uh a
couple personal questions maybe uh you
know when you're not being
obsessed with uh with reading research
papers and things like that what do you
like to do for fun
yeah so i mean i really like to balance
my digital life with like a physical
existence as well so i'm actually like a
really uh really passionate rock climber
like um i picked up rock climbing like
you know a couple of years ago
and it's it's really been my antidote to
like when i spend too much time in front
of a screen i really enjoy like going
out into the mountains and doing some
rock climbing
oh you actually do you have to go out in
the mountains uh
yeah so i mean here here in belgium
belgium is pretty flat we don't have a
lot of mountains but when we go on
vacation we go to spain or to italy and
there's plenty of mountains plenty of
rock and then yeah oh very awesome uh
and i guess finally uh since you're
belgian uh what's your favorite belgian
beer
oh we have so many i i i don't think i
could pick a single one like there's a
cafe not far from where i live and the
menu literally has like 2 000 beers and
i don't think i've even tasted all of
them but but if i had to pick one i'd
say omega is probably one of my
favorites i i don't even think it's that
famous outside of belgium we just have a
lot yeah okay well maybe next time i
visit i'll have to go go try one yeah
yeah for sure for sure all right
excellent well uh xander thank you so
much for for taking some time to chat
with me today um this is really fun
wonderful awesome okay
[Music]
you